- Oh my gosh.
It's nice to see you again.
- It's so good to see you.
- You did so good in the movie.
I'm gonna get to it,
but I was like, okay pop star.
With all the moves
and the sexy faces.
- I was so nervous.
Oh my, there's an art to the well,
which we'll get into later
with the hair whip and the sexy face.
But I may not have you
in my ear as my muse
when I was very nervous.
- Oh my God,
not for that muse.
- I had three days.
- I was watching, I was
like, what's up Brittany?
Oh, that was so nice.
Have y'all met before?
Have you met JB?
- You know, we were on a show together.
I was on Woke season
two, but we've never met.
- We never met each other.
- Oh my gosh, that's so funny to me.
Cause when you're not in
scenes together, then you-
- [Aimee] No.
- I was a pen, so, I was a pen.
I just voiced a pen.
- You were a great pen.
- Thank you.
(celebrities laughing)
- That's amazing.
So let's talk about the movie. I love it.
'Christmas With You'.
Have you always want, I love Christmas.
Have you always wanted to
do like a Christmas movie?
- Always, always, always.
And you know, when I was growing up,
a movie with a Latino family
in a Christmas classic
never existed.
Ever.
And I was like, oh, well
it'd be nice if someday.
And I was so flattered and
honored when Netflix was like,
because of the musical
episode, do you wanna do this?
- [Kelly] In Lucifer?
- [Together] In Lucifer.
- With the very charming
Freddie Prince Jr.
And it's about a pop star,
who, you know, think
Beyonce, J Lo, who has fame
and fortune and Grammies,
but doesn't have love.
So she-
- I know nothing of that.
(crowd laughing)
I just look, I had to,
you have to make it funny.
Or you cry.
So, no, but I do, I love the movie.
I love the whole premise of it.
- Aww, thank you.
- So you end up going home or to his
because of his little girl.
- Exactly. So it's very organic.
You know, she sees this 15-year-old girl,
14-year-old girl, soon
to be 15 and be like, oh,
I wish that this, my favorite, you know
singer could come give us a hug and-
- Oh, it made me cry. Her video?
- Oh good.
- Yeah, I was like,
you're like, oh good.
No. I was, I was crying.
I was like, oh my gosh.
What a way to connect.
- Yeah, well, you know what
I love about this movie?
It has all the things that
you love about Christmas
like heart and humor and romance but-
- [Kelly] Music.
- Because, and music,
but because it's told
from a Latino perspective
it has tequila and tamales
and a little bit of Spanish.
And we had a Latina director.
You know, Gabby Tagliavini
and we have a Latino producer.
Herman Torres.
And we have Latino writers.
So I really commend Netflix
for making this movie
because it's trailblazing
with not only two Latino leads headlining
a Christmas classic
but also having diversity
behind the camera.
Which I think is pretty unprecedented.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
I didn't even know all of that.
That's incredible.
And just for you watching,
even if you don't know that,
it was just a really cool,
I was like, this culture
is so beautiful.
And the family, it's just
like, the family element
was like really just attractive.
It was captivating.
- And universal, you know,
because we've got, and
it was really, I mean,
I freaked out a little bit
'cause I only had a week
of dance rehearsals
and I was dancing with
actual professionals
who are professional-
- You must be a really
good dancer in life then.
- Well, So I danced with the-
- 'Cause even when you
were slightly doing stuff
I was like, okay, Aimee.
I was like, yeah. Yeah!
- Well I started as a
dancer back in the day
but it's been a long time.
- That's why.
So they're like, you're gonna be dancing
with the Brooklyn net
professional dancers.
And I'm like, okay, okay.
And they're like, you have
five days of rehearsals.
I'm like, okay, okay.
Like, you have three
days to learn the songs.
I'm like, okay, okay.
And our choreographer's amazing.
She's Jessica Castro and
she worked with Maria Carey
and Alicia Keys,
Beyonce, J Lo.
- Never heard of them.
- Yeah, and she sat me
down and she's like, look,
you're playing a pop star.
You need to know about the hair whip.
And I'm like, well, what
do you mean the hair whip?
And she said, you have to
fully commit to the hair whip.
All of these divas really
know how to whip their hair.
And if you don't do it correctly,
it will land in your face.
So, you know, as she says
there, you can't think side.
Sorry, I'll try to, I don't know if I
can even do it right now.
But you can't think side side, okay JB?
- You gotta swing up.
- You gotta think full, full.
- Oh my, see?
See?
- I'm so glad, I'm like, I
don't know if it's gonna work.
- You were so natural at it though.
I was like, you could have had...
(crowd laughing)
- That was good.
You nailed it.
- [Kelly] Your hair just blowing.
- We'll put the hair in later.
Put the hair in later.
- Yeah, extensions.
- CGI.
Oh my God, that was incredible.
- Full disclosure, I
was very, very nervous
and very intimidated about the singing.
And I would just like play you,
you know how you have your rock,
whatever your rocky song is.
And I was like, "what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger."
"What doesn't kill you makes you stronger."
- Oh my God.
- And I was literally like,
I was like, I can do this.
I have three days, but if I just sing
from the heart and I'm like,
what are you guys thinking?
Like voice wise, like, you
know, like Kelly Clarkson-
I'm like, whoa.
You're thinking like the best
singer of our generation?
Not gonna happen in three days.
But I'm gonna do my best.
- Oh my God, you did so great.
It was so great.
- Yeah, so you were my muse.
And I just wanted you to know that,
seriously.
- You are very kind.
You're always so nice to me.
Well, thank you very much.
Everybody you gotta check
out 'Christmas With You'.
It starts streaming on
Netflix, November 17th.